this episode is sponsored by better hell
hey y'all
I'm here I'm trying so hard to Bap but
uh I'm sorry I've been inconsistent with
episodes I know we had to take a couple
weeks off just a little bit of an update
here a couple things are happening first
of all I have hypothyroidism
sorry
this is so anti-climactic it's like you
know what you know with like celebrities
like come forward like guys I need to
share something with you I have Lyme
disease
care I'm a little sleepy lately I'm I
need to I'm Thai Thai you guys I've been
soups Ty Ty
it is real though when he told me about
it I was like ah this is like not it
I'll beat this like it is so
gnarly dude it basically means my
thyroid is working about as well as the
sequest Titanic tour boat that basically
ended up being an easy bake coffin that
was operated by a uh
yeah what was that a video game
controller from Radio Shack yeah
so being pregnant is pretty cool uh the
baby just uses your thyroid just to LIT
I don't know it's just a little vampire
just slowly kills your brain and sucks
your heart out and to just starts I
don't know snorting your thyroid out of
your head so already a great start
to Motherhood
um but I don't know it's I it feels like
oh my God complaining about being tired
is literally I hate it when people
complain about being tired you know when
you ask someone how they are they're
like I'm just like really tired they're
like go to bed like stop talking about
it but I do feel like I owe everyone an
explanation for why I've been kind of
M.I.A and podcast episodes haven't been
coming up so I just it's like did you
ever have mono in high school bat I
heard about it constantly nerd okay good
because whoever did I used to make so
much fun on the mono people that were
just like you can't even make out with a
stranger without napping for seven
months like pulling together dude but I
guess that's what it feels like
um anyway speaking of kissing strangers
Adriana chechik is our guest on the show
today Adriana is an adult thespian she's
won over 35 awards for her work none of
which I can name on here or the YouTube
doors will restrict this video like they
did the Riley Reed one
um YouTube I don't know what's going on
on it's it's turned into Disneyland uh
and it's just very frustrating because
you guys have wanted me to have Adriana
for so long and now I feel like there's
a lot we have had to bleep or sort of
creatively cut around there's a couple
parts of it that I'm just gonna put on
my only fans page because I know it's
gonna you know get us punished in the
YouTube algorithm but um if you don't
know Adriana a 2019 Jezebel article on
female
how can I say this word without you into
the hard J
easy female ejo ejaculation no it's a
heavy metal detector the whole show
female I mean can we say it is peeing
we've learned from the episode today so
female peeing is that gonna get us
kicked out female pleasure peeing
female happy P
um
Adriana is a delight she has so much
wisdom Insight she's been through a lot
incredibly resilient it's always cool to
talk to someone who it keeps Reinventing
herself she sort of shares with us how
she literally and figuratively got back
up after falling down she is a dream uh
Indy 100 described chechik as one of the
most famous names in
pound
is that gonna get it you can't say that
I think they're saying corn online corn
we're gonna call a daughter David now
corn corn Stars okay she's a corn star
yeah corn on the cobb star I will say
that um some of our conversation does
involve how to
happy p uh and again that will be on my
of profile because YouTube is being run
by Nuns with OCD I don't know what's
happening I love you guys enjoy Adriana
chechik I'm gonna go back to sleep for
the third time today
you're making me nervous
I'm nervous I get nervous do you get
nervous before podcasts I get nervous
before everything super nervous really
yeah my hands get sweaty and stuff
what's the worst that could happen
that's what my therapist makes me do
whenever I'm like nervous about
something she's like let's walk through
the worst case scenario
I'm like you're fired yeah nothing
really I just get nervous I don't know
like what's gonna happen when you start
to actually think like what's gonna
happen you're gonna say something dumb
fine then we'll cut it out yeah fine
you're gonna
you know it's only uphill from here
um so earlier we were talking about a
very traumatic uh situation in your past
where you're emotionally harmed I
believe it's uh being on a podcast
called two bears one cave yes
are you recovering from this emotional
trauma I have recovered from this
emotional trauma um birth still keeping
their relationship alive
it's ongoing so is he just in your DMs
constantly yeah he actually sent me I
think he sent everybody uh when his
movie came out he sent the white
Russians right right right I got it at
11 A.M so I got wasted so I never had
one and I was so hung over the next day
I had to order an IV and I was I
couldn't even go to his Premiere because
I was like I'm so hungover
yeah I remember so at the roast of Burt
Chrysler that we did for only fans TV
that's where you and I met yeah right
and Bert like Bert doesn't really get
nervous yeah he doesn't really get
nervous he's you know he's burnt he's
topless more than you are at this point
and he started getting really flustered
and nervous at the premiere and I didn't
understand what it was like oftv the
launch you know it's all these comedians
are there and then we were on the red
carpet he's showing his belly he's got
you know being silly
it just starts with some muttering start
he's like my favorite porn stars here
and I'm like what is
this dude she doesn't know you yeah she
doesn't see you back through the camera
like I don't think she knows what you've
done no to her
she doesn't care I mean I don't know if
I want an image
I was just like if you don't tell her
she won't know yeah totally so just play
it cool oh my gosh but you got to meet
him that night right yes yeah he's
actually so nice the greatest out of
everyone I've ever met he's always like
if you need help with marketing if you
because I was uh I'm in the midst of
starting a podcast as well like
everybody good good he's like oh if it's
a good podcast like we can help you out
with that as well and I'm like just to
be a big star and to be so helpful is so
nice because you don't see that
happening often yeah he is the most salt
of the earth like just great dude and
really shows up yeah you know how crazy
he is let me ask you okay so you went on
their podcast you've been going on lots
of podcasts it feels like you're in a
big career like transition at the moment
yes yes I'm trying well I'm not trying
I'm definitely not shooting porn anymore
I'm officially retired and was this
before the back injury
um so before the back injury I did say
I'm retired from shooting with companies
because I just felt like the the power
of doing only fans and controlling what
I do on set myself was so much better
and then honestly uh there's like this
weird thing in porn like where the
directors hype you up they're like oh my
God you're doing so great oh my God this
is amazing you're so awesome so then
you're like doing a sex scene for like
two or four hours or you're like okay
maybe I wasn't gonna do like DP today
with these two guys but now I'm gonna do
it because you're telling me how awesome
I am so I was just like I just want to
work around females and I just want to
shoot my own content females are like um
can you suck it in please yeah yeah you
look terrible you have a double chin
they're like your extensions are showing
like I've literally had one time my
extensions showing and no one told me
and I'm like what the fuck is that guys
the guy would never notice that oh no
we're just like cool she's doing the
dreads thing now sick yeah
yeah so then um after I hurt my back I
thought maybe I'd go back to porn but
obviously I can't move the same way yeah
um and then the fear is the fear that
kind of like pushed me into making the
decision is I don't want people to say
oh well she was so much better before
and it's really because normally I'm
good at not listening to the noise but
lately
I'm listening to it so intensely so I'm
like I just don't want people to say
like oh wow she's so much better this or
that and I just want to reclaim my
person like who I am outside of the
brand that I've built so I'm like I
don't want to send nudies I don't want
to do any more pornos like I want to be
selfish with my body no one else
deserves it except for me so did you
always because I feel like I was
watching something of yours where you
kind of had the mentality like I'm gonna
do is go as far as I can go and then I'm
gonna sort of use it for everything I
can get out of it yes like was that
always kind of in the back of your head
yeah like the goal is when you get in
sex work the goal is to get out of sex
work that's what none of these like big
stars talk about right it's fascinating
because the reality is you don't want to
stay in porn forever you don't actually
want to do sex work you can enjoy it but
you really don't want to do that job
right so you have a great time and
you're enjoying it but the goal is like
okay now I can retire now I have a brand
to live off right
um and I don't think a lot of a lot of
people talk about that but it's crazy
because when you do get out of the
industry you get alienated by the
industry like Mia Khalifa porn stars
will be like oh she's such a blah blah
blah same thing about
um you know in my business when you stay
in it they call you really when you
leave they're like oh she seems cool but
if I stay in it they're like competition
yeah competition yeah they want you to
get out of it I feel like well the male
directors and the people that kind of
control porn
um they're the ones that start the
conversation against the women who have
left porn so they kind of keep you in
that system
and that's also another reason why I
want to get out of it because I'm like
I'm tired of being a part of this
system that keeps happening and I didn't
see a lot of the manipulation that was
going on like I did a lot of things of
my own accord I enjoyed them with my own
accord but just like I shot on average
for five years 25 days a month mostly
anal scenes and I would tell my agent
I'm tired and you'd be like oh well
Adriana
um
someone's telling us you're getting fat
and then I'd be like Oh I'm gaining
weight I gotta work out I'm not tired
anymore because I'm too busy thinking
about how fat I am also guys love that
yeah they love a jiggly cushion for the
person I love when you fluctuate too
because then it's like you get a little
bit you get like skinny me you get like
yeah yeah you're getting all these
different yeah totally have a kid you'll
be MILF like if they don't you know
they'll take it all yeah so there was
like a lot of distraction tactics that I
realized
um recently that I'm like I just want to
be being a part of anymore and also that
like guilting that shaming that pressure
as if we don't put enough pressure on
ourselves like that pressure of just
like I'm gonna lose this this is gonna
go away if I don't keep doing it and
that's not for the right reason yeah
well I I can work at Walmart and be
happy like I I worked at CVS Walmart has
good benefits yeah I'm like you know
once I realized like I when I was fine
working normal jobs before I was ever
even anybody I'm like I can be fine just
being nothing again like I know I can
always make enough to cover myself and
be happy and that's all that really
matters can you imagine checking out at
Walmart
and her being the cashier oh my god dude
that would be so chaotic I feel like you
should do a show where you just do
Basics
watch people lose their minds totally
totally you know but I do feel like you
know and I know I tend to you know
compare sex work and and comedy a lot
stand-up comedy you know it's like you
know they started in the same space you
know stand-up comedy really in America
started in strip clubs we've all kind of
like always been like hand in hand you
know a lot of friends that are in sex
work and and dancers and stuff and you
know it's funny because
um I feel like for the most part
strippers and and sex workers kind of
looked out on us they're like oh God
like we we show our bodies but you guys
exploit like your lives and your secrets
and yours like mine you know like like
have some self-respect like when I go
into strip clubs they're like how you
doing really like you okay I love
comedians because I feel like you guys
are my groupies oh like comedians love
me you know like comedians love me so
I'm like you guys are my group yeah it's
so true
I think stalker is the word yeah I've
given him a lot of gold I guess yeah and
I think that the ones especially the
ones that you know that that gravitates
towards you I think are like really
happily married good dudes you know that
like aren't like spooky and yeah you
know creepy um let me ask you do you
feel like had you not had that freak
back injury this is when you would have
stopped or did you feel like it was in
the back of your mind or you feel like
the universe had to come in and kind of
intervene or like it was like a sign
like all right this needed to happen I
think I think it would would definitely
have stopped so like I started streaming
and I got a lot of power and having
people realize like who I am for my
personality and enjoying seeing me like
on Twitch or just like playing video
games or just on any other platform
doing non-sex things to where I was like
wow I have so much more power than just
selling my body and that's kind of when
I decided to like get out of it and then
you know right now I've like expanded on
trying to teach like other people other
creators how to run your stuff without
men because I'm so I love you guys but
I'm so for like women building women
teams so I have um like your creators
University class that I'm working on I'm
trying to go into motivational speaking
as I fix myself awesome awesome yeah and
um if you feel comfortable talking about
that
um you know I think that it's it maybe
we both have this Maybe not maybe I'm
trying too hard to connect but you know
I'm in a job where I feel like I can
kind of stay broken for a very long time
and it would either benefit me or just
sort of keep me asleep or you know like
I in a lot of other jobs you know we're
not alone all the time where you're not
kind of going on stage making fun of how
horrible your decisions are and
everybody laughs sometimes you get
encouraged for staying broken you know
and so for me it's like I have to
actively kind of like go I need to
mature around this I need to heal this
wound even though this wound might be
helping me in some way you know or this
you know low self-esteem or this high
tolerance for being used or you know
this codependence you know like this
might be benefiting me but like I'm
gonna have to put myself first and heal
and you know now we were talking about
you know trauma and the trauma response
is real like it is
you know and it tricks you into thinking
you've healed that because I'm like what
do you mean how could I be traumatized
look how confident I am like I'm playing
these huge theaters or just like what
are you doing you know like fight or
flight for me it's like every time I
would get upset about something or
anytime I would feel like my life was
out of control or crazy I just work
harder and for the longest time I didn't
want to fix the problems I had because I
was like I would tell people I'd be like
oh well if I didn't grow up the way that
I grew up I wouldn't be here today like
I wouldn't have tried hard enough to get
here but the reality is I could have
grown up another way and still achieved
the same thing because I'm I'm the
person that I am but for a long time I
was just like oh it's the situations
that made me push hard but like no it's
a way of kind of making it so that it
wasn't so bad I had to make it some kind
of Advantage you know I'm like well had
I not had this abuse like I wouldn't be
this strong and like I hadn't had this
abuse I wouldn't have gotten funny you
know and it's like no no it's it's is
that just me you know trying to like
pretend it didn't happen sanitize it or
like to not have to accept how bad it
was yeah because I don't want to be a
victim yeah totally you know and so like
what are you looking at right now where
you're like this is something I want to
look at this is something I want to
maybe heal like
um well first of all I definitely want
to heal like I I don't think I've ever
had like and this might be crazy but I
don't think I've ever had true love for
myself so I'd love to find love for
myself I'd love to be happy in my own
body
um I started porn when I was 21 and
before that I was stripping so I've
never gone by my own identity like in my
head I didn't think my real name until
like six months ago so I feel like I'm
just learning exactly who I am like I'm
like oh shit I like this type of music
yeah not this type of music so I want to
figure out how to get into my skin and
just be like you're enough you love you
and that's the purpose and like who were
you before all this do you you know and
do you feel like you know because I
started doing stand-up around that time
and it was always like how do I become
funny to these people like how do I you
know make these people like me and I I
in relationships I was you know wrote a
book about being codependent about how
it was like you know I was so
identity-less or I thought I had to kind
of shape-shift in order to
um people please others so it was like
yeah if you want to go get Mexican food
I love America I do love Mexican food
but you know it's sort of like I was so
deferential to other people or I would
so sort of like you know morph my
identity into what I thought they wanted
I found my found myself like out of
relationships being like I don't even
know who I am really I even did it in
friendships you know I'd be in a friend
group where I was like oh they go out
and they party friends they go and they
party so I guess I'm this person because
oh you're not gonna drank and you're
like I guess I'm the drinking girl now
you know and then I kind of
um landed with like wait a second like
you know just between me and my like I
had to do this like inner child work
where I would you know you write in your
dominant hand yeah questions during your
child and respond and your non-dominant
hand and it's like this weird little
magical exercise that helps you sort of
reconnect with like what you're about
did you find in relationships you strong
struggled with I was in a relationship
for 10 years so pretty much my whole
porn career we were open
um looking back on it he was not the
nicest guy to me he was 20 years older
than me
um so he would Gaslight me a lot like
he'd be like oh I'll give you like
Adderall or Molly and then he turned
around and be like you're a drug addict
you're a really bad person you're a drug
addict and then he would constantly be
like oh you're fat and you would
actually try and control my food a lot
so that's why now currently have such a
hard time looking at myself in the
mirror not because of what the world has
said about me because that one person
has fed into me for so long
um and then I think that I just because
everyone pumped up that it was cool to
be sexual yeah I over sexualized myself
and I lost myself in my sexuality and I
think that's I literally just like
picture myself being like a blow up doll
for the past 10 years of my life you
know just floating around from place to
place being like oh this is great I'm
entertaining you you know yeah like the
orgasms are real yeah that that was
great but you know it was a very crazy
it's crazy experiences you know and then
also to like what you said like you know
I think when I see you online or
whatever people being so mad at like the
Kardashians or you know the Vogue
magazine or whatever about like
unrealistic body image like yes I'm sure
we don't you know can't really like
prove causality with all that kind of
stuff yeah like it sometimes can just
take one person that that
psychologically abused you so much that
that's where your body image stuff comes
from that's where your stuff you know so
it's like when people are running around
with like you know let's get mad at the
models and stuff like that I'm like
that's not how psychological abuse like
we don't talk about that enough in
relationships when we're you know this
this sort of Stockholm syndrome of
someone that is taking the time and when
you've gotten so little love like I got
so little love growing up and neglect at
best that by the time someone was paying
any kind of attention to me even if it
was needed it even if it was you need to
gain more you need to lose way but your
boobs need to be bigger and this needs
and your hair should be longer and you
should talk like this and act like this
it was kind of like someone cares yes is
kind of like what it felt like and it
took me so long to put together how
toxic that was yeah and I was actually
kind of
um putting him as like a kind of a in a
weird way of Father Figure sure yes
because growing up in foster care I did
know my mom she was super not so but I
put him kind of in that role like where
he would care for me and a lot of the
times I'd be tired even in like shooting
porn and he'd be like well you want to
be Adriana you got to go today you know
so like a lot of the time they went to
shoot just because he would tell me to
shoot and looking back on it like there
was no reason for me to be shooting 25
sex scenes a month like there's no
reason I could have shot five scenes a
month and still built a brand like I
didn't have to exhaust myself I didn't
have to have like UTIs and yeast
infections and I had to get stitches
multiple times I'll I'll say this one
time I worked uh five days after getting
an abortion because my my agent made me
and he was like oh you're just going to
shoot anal so I shot an anal scene after
that and it was like crazy that I didn't
even stop to think like how traumatic
that was and I was 20 I was 24 at the
time until like last year hey y'all as
you know this show is brought to you by
better help life is a nightmare and of
all the things that I've tried to make
life more manageable and I've tried it
all tried it all folks weed mushrooms
astrology denial Tide Pods gold digging
even the most expensive Hollywood Cults
couldn't do the trick for me the only
thing that truly works on a cellular
level for me is talk therapy it creates
immediate relief gives me perspective
helps me not go to the problem for the
solution helps me delineate the
difference between feelings and facts so
that I don't take out my ephemeral
emotions on an innocent person or send a
tweet I will regret or these days a
thread I will regret thanks Mark Zuck
for adding another addiction into the
mix we all needed that we decided what
better way to show you guys how
effective better help is than to let
y'all in on a special session I had with
a better help counselor Jesu Joe is a
licensed marriage and family therapist
and she was kind enough to do some
segments with me hey Sue is the current
head of clinical operations at
betterhelp in this segment I'm going to
talk to her and ask her some questions
that y'all sent in trigger warning this
segment does mention sexual abuse and
regular warning I say some things that
are super embarrassing
Mark in Boston uh should I have a
therapist of the same gender
I mean I live in LA I don't see gender
but Mark does
um
I encourage folks to have a therapist
that they feel safe with sometimes
gender is affect a factor in that and
sometimes it's not
um I think the the most important factor
Beyond gender race your therapist
political alignment which hopefully
never even comes into it
regardless of all those things you need
to feel safe with this person or at
least in the beginning you need to feel
that you have hope that you can feel
safe with this person
um and if if
having a therapist of the same
presenting gender as you if that's what
helps you feel safe then go for it look
for somebody like that but I certainly
don't want people to hold themselves
back from working with somebody because
of a gender difference
um you know this is a human connection
and a human relationship and you're not
there to be sitting with someone that's
exactly like you
um if anything you're looking for
someone that can see things a little bit
differently to model and help you have
different kind of perspectives when
you're navigating life's challenges and
needing to problem solve
um so it's really it's really up to each
individual what they prefer a lot of
people will prefer something and that
preference can change over time too
and something that actually helped me
and you know I think it was because when
I started therapy I had so little money
that that you know spending money on it
uh I felt like I really need to get my
money's worth you know it was so you
know and and I think I actually derailed
uh uh what I was saying before one of
the biggest limitations of uh for me
going to therapy was having to drive
there having to get in the car having to
go sit in traffic having to go like feed
the meter it's like I was like going to
therapy causes more stress than whatever
you know so I think this you know doing
online has been just a freaking Miracle
um but
something that really helps me is to
just doesn't say that I realized I was
going to the therapist and I would lie
to him and I I don't know if I was
trying to just you know get him like be
liked be I also it's not uncommon in one
day I just said to him I was like I I
sometimes am not lie I lie to you
sometimes what's up with that and he was
like let's dig it and I was like what I
feel that I need to impress you I feel
you know for me and it was because we
had worked together for a while and I
didn't want him to think he was a bad
therapist so I was like trying to go
like and I'm doing much better in this
area now and you know I I broke up with
this guy which I had I just didn't want
him to think his therapy wasn't changing
me fast enough and he was like let's dig
into why you think I lose sleep at night
thinking I'm a bad therapist instead of
you prioritizing your health you know
mental health you know and I you know
it's part of the reason I don't do a lot
of things that would qualify as
self-care
um I've gotten two massages in my life
uh I've had to like they were gifts that
I the entire time was so stressful
because I was trying so hard to convince
the therapist how relaxing it was for me
and I was like performing like oh this
is amazing even though I like really
actually don't like people touching me
and you know I have sexual abuse in my
past and I actually was like
massages just aren't for me as of now
but I put myself in these incredibly
stressful situations that are supposed
to be relaxing and then spend all this
you know energy
trying to take care of the other
person's feelings I was trying to take
care of my therapist feelings
um do you do in the same thing with the
gender thing if you have a just say it
be like
is it weird that I think it's weird that
you're a guy is that let's just talk
about that just talk about the thing
that you're worried about
yeah it's
I encourage people to bring up anything
and everything in the room
your therapist
strong segment should be able to receive
the things that you're bringing most
therapists that have been practicing for
some time it's going to take a lot to
shock them yeah yeah we also go through
training and we have ethical codes to be
in consultation so that we're dealing
with our own stuff that's coming up from
things happening in session oh
interesting the feelings that come up
about a therapist from the client
because there are going to be those
personal things feelings of wanting to
take care of them of wanting to make
sure that they're okay take care of
their feelings like anything the client
is feeling on such a deep level about
the therapist specifically it has a word
it's transference and this is something
that people can look into if they want
to know more about it but it's very
common and it's expected by therapists
for clients to feel some type of way
about them in good ways and bad ways
ugly ways hard ways and then on the flip
side therapists are people we're just
people and we're going to develop
feeling about and towards our clients
too as other people that's called
counter transference
um and and it's my professional duty to
deal with that stuff so that you don't
have to take care of me you should never
be in a position to have to take care of
me
um that's not why we're here I am here
for you and the things that I need to uh
do to take care of myself that happens
outside and that's part of my
professional Duty as a therapist thanks
Jesu I'm all fixed
I forgive my dad now back to Adriana
so there's a lot of traumas that have
kind of built up for sure for sure you
know if I've learned anything I've tried
to outrun them you know but like they
catch up dude they're like little ghosts
just like on your heels they're like
when are you gonna process this wanting
to process this and you know a lot of
people don't talk about it I'm not
diagnosing you with this this is just my
experience with like workaholism you
know and it's a good way to mask things
and it's so rewarded with money with
Awards with accolades with you know I
went to a Workaholics Anonymous meeting
once that's a real thing oh yeah it's a
real thing oh totally oh my God maybe I
should get so fascinating because
because I've been an ACA adult children
about colics which just means you've
grown up in alcoholic homes and you have
other addictive behaviors that might not
be you know necessarily to external
substances it's more the internal drug
cabinet you know adrenaline you know uh
uh turns into dopamine so it's like
you're in dramatic relationships you're
in chaotic situation you know I would
find myself just like always you know
high on adrenaline and if I didn't have
chaos going on I had to kind of create
it or if I had like an empty day I had
to like find you know friends going
through a breakup so I'm over there
helping her move and helping go to a new
hotel just like always and then you know
it's the always the people that say like
I hate drama yeah those are the people
that qualify for the most part right
because you always are whatever you're
resisting but so I found myself being
like you know what other ways am I
anesthetizing you know I definitely did
with food for a long time with
restricting food
um with relationships like love
addiction stuff you know that shit is
real like the being in you know if they
Define an addiction as as when something
uh stops being fun or when it no longer
becomes a choice like when you're in a
toxic relationship and you're like I
know this is bad and I always have a pit
in my stomach but like I can't you can't
leave I can't leave yeah I wanted to
leave for five years but there's still
in my relationship for five years
because it either recreates your
childhood circumstances it recreates
some kind of want to be alone and I was
afraid I was afraid to be alone that's
exactly what it was and it's like I'd
rather be in the uncomfortable little
familiar than the uncomfortable
unfamiliar yeah you know and having such
low self-worth it's like what am I going
to do without this person exactly you
know what am I going to start over like
they've convinced me that I'm such a
piece of shit that like I'm not gonna be
able to function without them anyway
exactly and then you go like what am I
going to start over like who's gonna
love me you know so it's just but going
to Workaholics Anonymous meeting was so
wild everyone was like 45 minutes late
because they were all working yes we all
came in late and it was in LA so it was
all kind of like like known people you
know and the first thing we all said to
each other you know would be like hey I
love your work like such a big fan and
the woman running I mean he was like um
you're not allowed to say that uh here
and everybody goes around there was a
woman that was intensely addicted to
crafting like she couldn't stop crafting
and there was another woman who like had
a business and she would sneak out at
like two in the morning and go back to
her like Boutique yeah and like work on
stuff and you know and I was like that
sounds crazy and I was like wait a
second I wake up at two in the morning
and just do it from my phone yeah I mean
what's the difference you know that's so
true and the woman that was addicted to
crafting I was like that sounds crazy
and then two days later I'm in Instagram
like putting the little emojis up I'm
like you're crafting performance
stories what's the difference you know
totally and then at the end of um
12-step programs they go uh you know God
Graham is trying to accept things I
cannot change the courage to change the
things I can in the wisdom to the
difference keep coming back it works if
you work it and you're worth it but you
have to just go keep coming back you're
fabulous because it's you can't say work
yeah we're all just like never went back
was too busy but like glad I went you
know because it is a real drug you know
the shitty part about porn is you get
that dopamine release and what they
don't tell you and which I tell girls
all the time
um I think why a lot of porn girls
suffer with depression is because when
you're on set you're doing those
hardcore scenes everyone's praising you
and then you're having orgasms and then
the next day almost all my friends will
be like oh I'm so sad today today sucks
so bad and I'm like yeah because there's
a come down it's a literal come down and
people don't tell you that they don't
tell you to be prepared for that yeah so
instead of having to come down you're
just like I'm just gonna shoot every day
so I don't have to worry about it yeah
yeah just getting like all the attention
the accolades the actual dopamine yeah
would you this might be a crazy question
after that relationship would you
recommend an open relationship or do you
think they're possible and functional
okay so like what
what I feel like I should say for social
medias yes
true self my true self like before I was
in an adult and like my true self I
personally don't think open
relationships are beneficial I
personally don't want to be in an open
relationship like I want to find
somebody that I love enough to be bored
enough with to to hang around you know
because I think I think good
relationships are not necessarily like
boredom in a bad way but are just a
constant like that's what I'm starting
to figure out it's like I'm kind of like
talking to this guy right now and it's
just a constant steady like just nice
flow of things there's no like erratic
Peaks or you know lows and streams yeah
and I'm like this is what this is what
it should be and I love the idea of
telling them like I want to be with you
which is this is so boring and it's
perfect
the other day he was like oh great
where's your tongue on that one
um it's it it's you know I remember when
I was in the love addiction we're
recovery thing
um you know the sponsor was like uh and
I was like how do I know I'm in a
healthy relationship like I don't even
trust myself anymore you know and she
was like um you're gonna have to come to
terms with being bored because for you
what you think boredom is is actually
just Serenity yes exactly no surprises
no waiting for the other shoe to drop
just consistent and the key is
are you going to be able to handle
someone consistently loving you without
being disgusted by them yes totally you
know you know when I first started
dating this guy he actually wouldn't hug
me because I he was afraid to because
I'm so closed off
he was like really afraid it's really
crazy that I do sex work but I'm super
closed off like anyone around me will
not will not touch me
um I probably cried the only time I've
ever really cried is when my dog died
but I'm always like oh I don't like
holding hands and stuff like that
because so I've kind of gotten to that
fish that costs money yeah exactly
exactly so I've gotten to that with him
you know um and we're just dating
because I need to just be single for
forever and also just like moving slowly
like it took me so long to you know
actively like deprogram like you know
what we saw in movies and what we hear
in music which is like you meet and it's
this passionate thing like we should
have butterflies in your stomach that
means it's passion like no that's your
that's your a pit in your stomach saying
like this is bad news so like get away
from this person totally you know and
like we've completely like whether it's
movies whether it's TV whatever have
managed to Gaslight us into believing
that a pit in your stomach is
butterflies yes and that it's like your
soul mate it's Illusionist feelings and
the worst is when it's someone that you
actually like that's a good person and
you overdose on each other too quickly
yeah and it's just like too much too
fast see I haven't had that happen yet
okay so like you're taking it do you
have like like boundaries in place or
like we'll see each other a couple days
a week yes definitely do our own thing
so that's good what is the worst thing
someone could come up and say to you
like what is what is something you're
like that's fine and things were like
please don't do that because it seems
like you're in a sensitive place where
you're sort of ready to
you know treat yourself differently and
allow different energy coming at you and
for the people that want to get it right
yeah I think it's always helpful to I
think the worst thing somebody could say
to me is like I don't matter or my
opinions don't matter oh sorry I mean
like they see you in public and they're
like oh there she is
can you imagine so I would be like oh my
god there she is in Starbucks hey your
opinions don't matter I'm sorry I'm
sorry um what's the worst thing somebody
could say to me if they saw me and like
what what is a good way to approach you
if at all and what's the not way to do
it
um oh my gosh it's so hard I think it's
good to approach me by just like coming
up and saying hi and being like I hate
when people are like are you uh yeah
don't do this don't do this yeah just
like risk it and be like hey are you
Adriana I love your work great to meet
you can we get a photo recently
something that I've started to realize
too is I don't like when someone comes
up to me like a group of guys if you're
a group of guys don't waste your time
coming up to me to say hello because
you're taking like 10 to 15 15 minutes
out of my my time and then also a group
of guys together approach me differently
because they think that's how they can I
had a guy recently approach me and then
he got a photo then his friend got a
photo then he asked if he could kiss me
and I was like No And then he asked if
he could kiss me again and I still said
no and then what happened is is all
these other guys came and they were
taking the photo with me and the parents
started taking photos like they were
they were older kids but the parents
started taking photos but laughing right
like so like I am like you guys are
making me like a bad commodity right now
like I feel embarrassing me yeah I feel
like I'm at a carnival show like hello
here's the freak Show you know so like
stuff like that I think is terrible I've
also kind of don't wanna I really like
I'm sorry to my fans I don't want them
to come up to you right now because I'm
in a like a moment of healing right
um so what happens is when I go out and
a fan comes up to me and same out with
my friends uh and I'm going out as I say
this name because it's okay Des I'm
going out as Des then all of a sudden
fans come up to me and recognize me the
night turns into Adriana and then I'm
like oh let me go look at my hair and
makeup in the bathroom really quick in
case somebody else recognizes me my
friends start being like does that
happen a lot oh my God that's so cool
and then they start talking about my job
it'll literally be a 30 minute thing to
where all of a sudden the person that I
am is not out anymore and Adriana's out
so currently right now do you feel like
it's like an alter ego that you can like
click into for sure a hundred percent a
hundred percent it's like I don't not
multiple personalities
definitely like that for sure like hot
yeah Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde for sure 100
did you know you were gonna get this
famous
I've and the reason I ask is I have a
theory like
it's gross to say but a lot of people I
know that got they were like I knew I
was like you couldn't have been doing it
all being like this isn't gonna work out
yeah you know what I mean I actually
everything I've ever done I've always
been like I'm gonna achieve the best
like like
when I first got into porn I was like
I'm gonna be a van performer of the year
one day yeah so I definitely thought I
was gonna be big but
breaking my back changed everything
because I was really popular but then
when I broke my back it's just like that
news for some reason went around the
world yeah and because it wasn't porn
star breaks her back most of the
Articles were streamer breaks her back I
was I was in everyone's TV or their
living rooms they were talking about it
with their moms and stuff like that so
it was normalized and that's kind of
when I started going out and really
getting recognized yeah that's why I get
the negative swatting and stuff because
people are like oh stay in your lane or
you know I've gotten so much more hate
because twitch streamers don't want porn
stars coming into the twitch space you
mean uh not not the streamers
necessarily the fans some of the viewers
the viewership like there's so many guys
online that are just like what are you
doing here so that like you're you're
not doing anything men online love me I
don't know what you're talking about
yeah I play hardcore games too I'm like
I'm not in a fucking hot tub bro like
I'm playing a game better than you would
right now you know but they're just
crazy but that's kind of like common in
the Gaming Community like the doxing and
stuff like that like I've had boxing
I've never had swatting you've had a
tremendous amount of where people just
like call in a bomb threat and then the
SWAT team shows up at your house yes
it's wild normally it's something
crazier than that they'll be like ah
she's being held hot or she's holding
someone hostage in the house with a gun
you know and I'm like what I don't even
have a gun and it's just me you know my
dogs like dude that I have all kinds of
weird weapons and all the plants in my
bedroom I have like knives all like in
in like the plants and I'm like what is
my plan do I think I'm just gonna like
turn into a ninja all of a sudden like
what I don't know what I think my brain
just goes like no adrenaline is gonna
kick in that's exactly what I said and
I'm gonna have a common incredible ninja
or the same way the person that breaks
in is gonna be like this bitch is so
crazy that I'm just gonna like rethink
this I'm gonna Danny Trejo someone's
asking me that's what I'm gonna I just
figured if I just like throw it
it'll just like when it'll stick if I
throw enough of them like one of them's
gonna hit or they're just gonna give up
because they're gonna be like this I'm
done yeah um something that I find did
work during the pandemic I I don't know
a lot was going on and also nothing was
going on and I was like you know what
like we're home for the next year I mean
it seemed like we were never gonna open
up again I mean in terms of like
performing as a stand-up and I've been
shooting a couple movies and they
stopped production and it looked like we
were not gonna pick up for a long time
and I was like why don't I just dye my
hair blue like I had for like makeup
artists and friends that were like hair
artists that were losing like basically
all their income losing their health
insurance like we're moving home because
it's a job you have to do close to
someone and so I was like you know
what's the most expensive thing you can
do and they're like let's dye your hair
color I was like great let's dive dye
blue I've talked before about like my
comedy influences or influences as an
Entertainer or not just comedians but
also I love Dennis Rodman I always loved
it I just loved him I loved that he was
like and I you know played basketball
pretty seriously and I loved that even
when he was like you know had oftentimes
the most thankless job is you know
Defender rebounder like he was like I'm
entertaining you I'm gonna have blue
hair I'm gonna wear a wedding dress like
if you're paying money for a ticket like
you know and I just love that so as
people are scrolling through so your
Instagram everyone's just like we're at
home we're bored I was like I'm gonna
have blue hair and I'm gonna have the
most fun and like you know when else am
I gonna have blue hair exactly people
don't come up to you when you're a woman
with blue hair really they either think
that you're like nuts on drugs or they
just don't recognize you at all so I
should just dye my hair this might be
the time I'm just telling you in the
gaming Vibe like I dyed my hair blue
purple like all these different colors
and by the time someone heard my voice
to recognize me like I was kind of they
were like was that her like you know
Wigs Wigs yeah I could do wigs it works
I could do wigs it definitely worked for
me
so I did get Knocked Up okay it happens
so I've been going to doctors up the
Wazoo so they can put things up my Wazoo
and you know what aren't up the Wazoo
people at front desks at doctors offices
who are helpful in any capacity to get
you in to the Wazoo doctor since I found
out that I have a tiny vampire uh
growing inside me
and that I have hypothyroidism as well
as cysts in my boobs not the ones made
of silicone I also guess what have high
arches so I need Orthotics
all I know is this baby better be a
child star to make all of this worth it
turns out I'm a big old mess and thank
God I got pregnant at a time when zoc
doc exists because I am sick of calling
offices with landlines I've had it
ZocDoc is a free app where you can find
amazing doctors and book appointments
online we're talking about booking
appointments with thousands of top-rated
patient reviewed doctors and Specialists
you can filter specifically for the ones
who take your insurance are located near
you and treat almost any condition
you're searching for these doctors all
have verified reviews from actual real
patience not Bots the average wait time
to see a doctor booked on ZocDoc is
between 24 and 48 hours that is it what
a miracle you can even score same-day
appointments once you find the doctor
you want you can book them immediately
with just a few app Taps no more waiting
awkwardly on hold with some receptionist
weirdo listening to Enya go to
zocdoc.com Whitney and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today that sock
dogzeocdoc.com Whitney sockdoc.com
Whitney
I just gave birth that's what I was
saying I have PTSD exact time we get
spotted or something I get really crazy
or I'll actually think that it'd be
crazy to not get crazy it'd be crazy to
knock you crazy yeah it'd be crazy to
have swatters show up at your house and
be like no problem that was it like what
that would be a wild response yeah it's
like your body like if there's like a
cop that drives by my house where I hear
a helicopter or I hear a siren I
actually will run to my windows and be
like oh my God is it a bunch of police
right now like am I are they gonna like
come in and maybe shoot my dogs or
accidentally shoot me because every time
except for one time it's been the full
SWAT team the last time I had 18 guns
pointed at me the very first time I had
20 guns pointed at me and at the time
um I had I didn't have like a gate
around my house so I just had dirt and I
just remember being so upset because
they made me lay in the dirt to handcuff
me and I was like oh you know like and I
had to be like guys I'm just a streamer
and it was so dramatic because I just
have never seen like that many it's
scary having guns pointed at you too
because it was in the middle of the
pandemic so you're like oh fuck all
these coughs and all these stories
you're hearing at the same time and then
like those are big guns and they're
doing their job I mean they this is you
know I've they they assume that the call
is true which is their job you know but
if it's not true like you just rip my
rotator guy yeah yeah you know so the
the first time they came it was super
aggressive did they start to catch on
that so they have they do have me listed
but they still have to come
um the last time the sergeant finally
came and now it's not where they'll
tackle me or come in my house but they
still bring the helicopter that circles
around my house all the cars still come
um most of the time there's only a few
of them pointing guns this time
um and when I come out they're like I
can just come out walking with my hands
up and they're like oh hey it's you
again are you okay I'm like yep there's
actually two cops just beat a dork in
Grand Theft Auto yeah there's actually
two cops that know me for video games
and the one cop was like so have you
beat the video game since the last
swatting because I beat it two times I'm
like fuck you motherfucker no I haven't
why don't you just live with me so we
can cut this response time down but then
I remember in the middle of the pandemic
I had a guy jump my backyard fence and
no cops showed up I have at the time I
had a pellet gun and I think it was just
like a bum so he didn't know what was
happening oh God I shot with my pellet
gun and I was like get the fuck out of
here you know and he climbed back over
at the fence and everything like that
but the cops didn't come until the next
day and had to leave a voicemail because
it was after hours and I was just like
you guys will show up for swatting but
then like something real happens you
guys don't come like this is crazy it's
so crazy and then so having all that I
mean that's obviously like there's the
adult traumas like the recent ones which
like I haven't even gotten I'm like I
don't even know when I'm gonna get to
those yeah this thing that happened six
years ago I was an adult you're like
yeah I don't even know what category to
put that in yeah um you know but also we
were talking about that book called the
body that keeps the score of like how we
keep trauma in our muscles you know and
EMDR also really helped me eye movement
reprogramming and desensitization
because like we store you know the the
way that it was explained to me in
layman's terms and it's the only way I
know how to explain it is like you know
our brain takes in like three billion
pieces of information a second which is
you know it's tactile like what you feel
how you feel what you smell what you see
you know not just visually what you see
but all these other things how you feel
as well and so you know let's say
someone walked in here right now like
one of the traumas that happened to you
we got swatted a bunch of police came in
with a gun every you know basically your
brain stops
um it freezes fight flight freeze right
but the information is going to keep
going in and all the information that's
keep coming in is going to be filed
under the folder trauma right so so
basically in three years you're you know
at a friend's house and the wall is this
color blue yeah and you're you're not
you don't know why you're anxious and
you're short-tempered and you're annoyed
and you're jumpy and you don't know why
it's because like you know your brain is
like last time we were near this color
this happens
your brain is only designed to protect
last time there was a liquid death on
the table all of a sudden you're like
drinking out of a liquid death on births
podcast or whatever and you're like
you're anxious you're you're irritated
you don't know what so it's like there's
so much of this like anxiety that goes
on we don't know what it's coming from
necessarily and what EMDR does it like
deactivates those things I didn't
realize how much trauma I had this is
embarrassing around Christmas I hated
Christmas like I would go through malls
and like in October why is your
Christmas tree up it's good you know and
I never celebrated Christmas as an adult
never had a tree none of that and then I
realized like that's when most of the
abuse happened in the house people were
drunk relatives came you know so it
wasn't a happy holiday it was like the
pine smell and you know the cult the red
and the green like it just pissed me off
yeah you know and stressed me out and I
was like getting fights in relationships
and I would you know whatever and then
you know you'd go through the the
memories of the EMDR and you're like
okay this happened this happened what
was there what was behind you what did
you feel and you're like oh there was a
Christmas tree oh there was I was
opening a present oh this happened and
then you started breaking them down into
pieces and basically deactivating all
those associations yeah so you're not
moving through life just the word
triggered I feel like is so overused but
it's like constantly just being
triggered by stuff subconsciously
totally I like that what are some other
ways that you feel like your PTSD shows
up
um
well I don't like being alone in a room
with a man
um my effect is my PTSD shows up for
that
um hiking I get PTSD
um just because I had in the pandemic I
was saying earlier I had someone attack
me uh when I was out hiking by myself
and ironically
um I had just gotten my tits done and
then I got fat under my eyes transferred
or fat from here transferred under my
eyes so I don't know if you've ever seen
what that looks like but your whole face
is bruised and your eyes are bloodshot
red so I was in a sweatshirt
I was wrapped here and my fucking eyes
were bloodshot red with bruises
underneath of them and some guys still
approached me and then he was like Hey
I'm lost can you help me and I grabbed
my phone and the moment I looked out on
my phone he just tackled me I got so
lucky that my dogs they've never been
aggressive before but they were
aggressive they attacked him I kicked
him I got up he pulled my backpack and I
fell back down and I was able to wrestle
and get out of my backpack and just run
down the mountain and I like I called a
friend and I was like Hey we're still
meeting for dinner right in like 20
minutes and I started like yelling like
about things I was gonna do later that
day and then I called the cops when I
was down and the cops were pretty much
just like
the pandemic's crazy right now we can't
find him so I don't know what to tell
you and I was just like all right so now
like going hiking is really bad
um it's very hard for me to hike which
really sucks because it's something I
love to do like I would go out into the
Los Angeles National Forest by myself
for like two days you know with my dogs
and just like love it and I'm from
Pennsylvania the Wilderness is like my
favorite thing I hiked the Appalachians
for six months so like I would never do
that now like now on my hikes I'm like
terrified at night or like I do a lot of
night hikes
um
and I get I get so freaked out
um I also think
um whenever I stream now I get paranoid
because uh a lot of the swatting happens
when I'm streaming so I kind of have to
remember to like remain calm yeah and
then
um interactions with uh different types
of male streamers will give me like PTSD
because like I did something where I
talked to Andrew Tate and then after
that I got swatted and I got death
threats I got like a ton of bad stuff
happen to me so anytime I have
interactions with like big male
streamers that'll come into my chat and
do stuff I'll be like freaked out just
gives me bad vibes do you like worry
that they're like pranking you or like
just that their fans are gonna their
fans are just so aggressive their fans
are just like the alpha male typical
type personality and they're just so
aggressive alpha males don't act like
the alpha males are fucking I mean yeah
I know sorry I just feel like that word
sometimes like no it's Miss it's misused
a hundred percent it's the alpha sleeps
the alpha has nothing that's like Omega
bitch shit yes like that's what's that's
a problem it's been so misused yeah
because guys like I'm Alpha yeah the
alpha shells give me Divine masculinity
like that's what I want I want a guy
like that what do you can I uh give some
fan questions yes please they're sweet
they're actually really sweet really
okay oh well this one's not Burger Tom
I love Bert but I'm always gonna say Tom
you just don't take care of yourself
sorry man
he's too wild for me too he's like a 21
year old girl he doesn't burn dude he'll
drink like an Amaretto Sour like it's
nothing I'm like what are you drinking
but he's like just having a Zima I'm
like where do you even get these
beverages from the late 80s early 90s
right right like it's either you're
gonna drink Cheetos or wear flip-flops
not both you don't get to have both yeah
this is something actually for me I was
listening to you talk about something
and you've spoken out about 69ing and I
am with you on this yeah I hate it I've
never understood it it seems like dorks
that are obsessed with Tetris like I
don't like it it's never worked no
someone's always smelling a taint best
case scenario it's because it's only
good for them because they're getting
their stuck and they can smell our
pussies but like at the same time I'm
like it's like a concert you are
adjusting the whole time you're trying
to do it you're like oh let me just like
hold on let me get a little bit better
in here yeah like I just can't is it I
don't even know how it works like it's I
always thought it was on the side no I I
feel like guys always put me on the top
or they'll try and hold me one and then
I'm like oh God my head's so close to
the floor if you drop me I'm fucking
like standing up yeah I get a lot of
guys that want to do like a standing 69
like I get a lot of guys that are just
like hey Adriana you're gonna acrobat so
like let's do them today you know yeah
no no
nerds but 69 is the worst position ever
has anyone ever 69 and been like like
high five at the end I don't fucking
think so I don't know if they have
they're lying I just am like maybe like
maybe like female to female I think you
need like a snorkel I there's like we
need it there needs to be like a device
that's missing there's like a band maybe
like a something but I'm like has this
ever been cool or am I just horrible at
this no it's not cool like why am I
bombing like I feel like I'm bombing you
know
um this look everyone's all has this
question is squirting peeing how much is
P how much is Squirt I know she's so
sick of this question
um so squirting is definitely having an
orgasm while you pee yeah that's the
yeah
because like I'm having an orgasm while
I'm peeing it's just it's such a good
orgasm I'm not holding my bladder right
and that's exactly what it is and is
whether someone's good at it or not does
it have more to do with practice or
releasing your inhibitions is it more
mental or more physical I think it's
more mental you have to be able to let
go
um but I will say like before I do
Squirt scenes or anything like that I've
always masturbated in the bathroom
before the scene and warmed myself up
um because it's sometimes I think it's
it's also in a way intimate because it
takes time to get to that so you're
pre-relaxing yourself so that you're not
in this like yeah like oh we gotta hurry
up and fucking do it you know and then
like oh shit now it's not gonna work
um but yeah that's I like squirting I
have I I don't I don't think I can
squirt anymore since my back injury I
have really bad bladder problems so I
think I'm never going to be able to
squirt again I tried
I know
I was gonna say you don't have to go to
Home Depot to get as many tarps I
normally only fucked on my dining room
table so that's kind of nice uh I can
like my bed now
I've been having really comfy sex
okay like there's I feel like this is
opening up a whole new world
you know
your life's getting boring in a lot of
ways you're gonna have to have sex in
beds you're gonna be with a guy that
wants to hold your hand right right I I
welcome it I welcome it so much do you
have from the injury do you have more
like operation like surgeries or
physical therapy uh so I'm doing
physical therapy uh twice a week I'm
doing yoga twice a week I'm doing
massages once a week
um my bladder issues were trying to
figure them out now because uh when I
originally hurt myself I couldn't use my
bladder at all so I had no feeling so
they keep saying like maybe the nurse
will grow yeah right right but like what
happens to me is I never fully I can
never fully like empty my bladder I just
feel like I have to pee all the time but
then I'd like nothing comes out so I
think like that might be the only like
really really really long-term issue and
then you've seemed like oddly calm about
this whole thing like I was just like I
was watching just as as you were coming
on I was watching when you were first
talking about it and then like do you
like lose it every now and then then
um
in the beginning I did but I felt the
only reason why I was so upset about it
is because I was scared that I was never
gonna feel better
um and I couldn't think past the pain
but about a month into it I just started
to realize like you know you've already
overcome so many things in your life
like you've been through way many way
more trials than this and this isn't
going to keep you down and I just
learned a lot of paint a lot of patience
nothing a lot of patience and I realized
you can just think out of it like when
I'm in pain I'm just like if I just
don't think about it it doesn't hurt
like it's temporary yeah and I stopped I
stopped everything so after the first
week I was out of the hospital I stopped
pain pills because my mother was
addicted to them so I'm terrified even
in the hospital they were trying to give
me uh Dilaudid and I was like no no no
and before the surgery the surgeon
actually had to talk to me because I was
refusing it and she was like this is the
percentage of people that actually get
addicted from surgical procedures
because that's how much I was freaking
out about it yeah
um
so I got off everything I'm not on any
nerve blockers or anything like that
because I like to feel my body yeah um
do you sleep okay
yes and no it depends on the day I sleep
on my floor actually most of the time
walk on your table you sleep on your
floor I mean I use a lot of ice like I'm
I'm getting better at knowing how to
take care of myself like what what I'm
gonna do that's gonna irritate it the
next day or how how is it gonna feel if
I do this
um but one thing I like also kind of
hate is I have so many people that are
like oh you're such an inspiration and
you're doing so well and I'm like
because I'm a fucking camera yeah yeah
bitch you know yeah exactly right you're
seeing the highlight reels yeah but I
kind of just like it happened and I
can't change it I have to just accept it
and read through it just being an
inspiration bother you yeah because I
feel like I didn't do anything like
everyone everyone keeps telling me I'm
an inspiration for them and
I just feel like I just like got up and
walked
you know like I'm just like I just got
out of bed and walked and they're like
wow you're an inspiration but I don't
know maybe that's me like holding
holding it back or something so I think
it's also just like the way that you're
comporting yourself is not through this
like victim lens you know like you just
like like incessantly
um like turned it into like I'm just
gonna move through this like I'm not
gonna like dwell on the negative and I'm
not gonna like try to get pitied you
know I think a lot of people want to be
pitied yes
it's a little bit ooky and I think those
people like you know tend to stay
um in the I don't know it's like you
know people just like love being sick
yes that are always sick yes and like
you're kind of participating it I feel
like you're whether it's manifesting
this whether it's allowing this I don't
know I know that's not like science
technically but like you love being so
your brain can make you that way your
brain can totally make you whether it's
psychosomatic or whether it's your you
know uh it just you know I think it
keeps you in the state that you're in I
think you're not going to heal as well
if you're not visualizing like getting
better and it seems like you're just
like a get up off the ground type of
bitch totally and I think I think I I
see why it's annoying it bothers me too
yeah when someone's like you inspired me
to overcome your eating disorder I'm
like I didn't try to do that I just like
yeah I just did it and I'm actually kind
of annoyed that I shared it because not
like I'm now I'm embarrassed that I
shared all that like I wrote a book I
was just trying to be honest and I wish
I hadn't frankly because now I have to
think about it all the time and it's
like I'm thought of as that you know so
it's like I wasn't trying to inspire you
I was kind of just trying to like not be
full of shit and tell the truth but it's
like I think that you're just you
probably don't know how
uncommon it is for someone to be as
resilient as you yeah
[Music]
yeah Twitter like it's just like
constantly that's the only question
people ask me now is like how's your
back you know and it's just so redundant
yeah to where I'm just like you know
like like you play video games all day
how's your back yours is probably worse
than mine yeah like uh when I was on my
vacation that article that came out I
was actually happy about because I was
like oh it's saying like Adriana's
partying in Mykonos like smoking a
sheesh and I was like this is the first
article that's come out where like maybe
you guys will see that like I'm okay and
even if I'm not okay to you it's not
your job to keep asking me if I'm okay
yeah you know like I I love people for
caring yeah but it's also a lot a lot
more stressful and they also uh
unknowingly kind of put a burden on you
by constantly having to remind you or
because you're having to have you be
like no I am fine like it's just or it's
like you're trying to feel sorry for me
or like get in all my trauma or
something and you know but it is also
just like it's this very very unique
situation where like just some wild
thing was caught on camera oh my God and
they actually ended up getting a towel
to put it in front because so many
people were there like taking pictures
why did it take so long for them to get
you
um I don't know it doesn't they also
moved me four times
um prior to the EMT getting there they
also put my they were moving my head
trying to put my hair up out of my face
so they did a lot of terrible things I
got so lucky that this random dude if I
ever find him I'd love to give him a hug
uh ran over after about 20 minutes of
them trying to move me and he was like
I'm an EMT I saw what happened she
either slipped something or broke
something you were damaging her more and
he grabbed my hand and he looked at me
and he was like you're gonna be okay I'm
gonna make them stop moving you oh God
and like him holding my hand just and
just telling me like it's okay and these
people are gonna stop touching you made
it so much better and like literally got
me through the last like 40 minutes
until I was able to get in that
ambulance and that's so awesome dude
yeah he was the best guy ever and he was
also really hot he's like shlom sir
would you recall anything about this man
please come forward identify yourselves
sir I would love to know you okay so
then let's stop talking about that
um do you ever see yourself settling
down and living a domestic life it seems
like uh you kind of answered that yeah I
do I do I definitely think so I I
definitely think I could lead a normal
life oh this is I do think that that you
know people say this kind of about
Comedians and then I I think this of of
sex workers and people that have you
know have I think you're like uniquely
qualified to understand human nature
like no one else does because you see
people not pretending you see people
sort of like at their most authentic or
like
um least ashamed or something you know
and uninhibited what do you think the
foot fetish is if you had to guess
why it's so big like why yes
there's a couple theories about it I'm
just obsessed with it without any
judgments or Kink shaming I'm just
fascinated well I like feet too okay
and I think the reason why I like fee
and the reason why I think it's such a
big thing is it represents femininity oh
because the way a woman has her arch in
her feet or the way her toes are and
also feet are very delicate yeah and
they are let me show you one of your
whole body oh right they're strong
they're delicate it's the most important
part of your body if you didn't have
your toes you can balance you'd fall
over but so it's not because toes look
like little dicks no
[Laughter]
no I look like little dicks oh no mine
look like big dicks oh my God that's
hysterical I've never heard that that's
like that's like that's like the theory
of like the pimple popping Theory like
where girls like to pop pimples because
it reminds them of like come coming out
oh yeah and I love come yeah coming
towards my face really quickly I didn't
think about that I love popping pitbulls
yeah but there's a huge theory that
women like it because it's the same same
thing as oops
hold on wait what's happening here oh
goodness there we go because it's just
retired doesn't know her way around a
phallus that was fast because it's the
same thing as like drinking off a dick
you're gonna get a white explosion in
your face and that's also part of why
men like guns right because it's like
um
it's weird how they associate these like
weird things to us like my dude I got
those Elon Musk flame throwers Elon Musk
made these like flame throwers that just
has like gasoline and just like spits
fire out get you one for next time you
get swatted dude you'll just get without
my face dude you're I'm gonna give you a
flamethrower next time you go hiking
when someone tries to mess with you you
just set them on fire wildfires you did
not start by me
and the first time he shot it off he
literally went
I was like did you just awesome yeah I
was like he's like that's kind of what
shooting guns like is and I was like ah
that's hysterical the other theory about
the um the and these are just
psychiatrists like being masturbatorians
probably their own weird stuff that
they're projecting onto us cathexis the
theory that like when babies crawl
across carpet and they see their mom's
toes it's like it feels good on their
genitals and they're like looking at
feet and like cathexis happens in their
brain that's bizarre that's a bizarre
take it feels like it's like reaching a
little bit I feel like it's reaching
because I know guys that have developed
feet fetish because of me or like who
didn't have it before like it's not
innate yeah yeah and they've developed
it so that one just sounds a little
bizarre to me yeah it's also like you
know is that issues change like maybe
he's like only addicted to certain feet
or you know stuff like that do you need
your guys to be pedicured
no okay I mean I don't like nasty feet
but I'm also somebody that like likes me
likes men
um and then I'm also not judgmental like
to be honest like if you like if you
have really stinky feet I'm gonna be
like wash them like if you have like
feet smelling like if your fucking body
smells like that's just people do you
prefer your pubes or no pubes
um well I have a bush but I think hair
is like super important to protect you
yeah I was meant to protect you dude my
dude is like a bald cat like younger
guys they're all oh I don't like it for
I don't I hate it I hate a ball I like I
need some pubes man yeah it's like you
have to fight tooth and nail to get puke
I'm gonna buy him a merkin it's kind of
weird though when they shave it all off
and I think it's not like totally you
know it's not big chemo energy but it's
you know it's kind of like I just I like
I like hair on toes hair on fingers yeah
I like just like yeah you know well hair
has its own like oil meals that give off
pheromones so that's another reason why
I like hair down there on me and my
partners I think it's like guys think it
makes it look better I'm like I know
what you're I know how big it is and
it's like it's not this optical illusion
that you just saw either way it's gonna
be I'm gonna know yeah sooner or later
how big it is totally you know
um oh fuck Mary kill Donkey Kong Kirby
Pikachu oh okay
um
sneak peek of your podcast life
I think I would kill Donkey Kong because
he just seems like crazy and just be
like throwing bananas everywhere
I don't know if I want that type of life
um and who were the other two Pikachu
Pikachu and Kirby
Kirby oh Kirby's annoying as fuck
um so I just fucked him
and I married Pikachu
no I never have to pay for like
electricity you know just like spark up
the house babe what are your top
favorite video games like if I'm gonna
start playing video games where should I
start my dude is very into this and we
got the PlayStation now I have the other
Xbox I have them all like where would I
start so I would say Alden ring it's the
best that's his favorite game yeah
that's like it's such an amazing game
it's such a like exploratory game so
Alden ring
um I would say after that a Jedi
Survivor or Jedi Fallen order is the
first one because it's just cool to have
a fucking lightsaber yeah
um I don't know if you like Star Wars
even if you don't it's just really
fucking cool and then uh this is an
indie game but it's called stray and you
are a cat in a post-apocalyptic world
and there's some really heart-wrenching
moments and some Beautiful Moments and
it's only a like 20 hour video game but
you actually play as the cat and the
designers did so well at making you do
cat shit that like there'd be like
beaded curtains and I'd be like I'm just
gonna play in this and then like 20
minutes later my child's like what the
fuck are you doing and I'm like I don't
know these curtains feel fine yeah
they're like roll the ball down the hill
or something oh dude do this with the
headset on no no no that's like yeah
just on a PlayStation what is up with
the headset like did VR porn ever catch
on because apple is trying to launch the
new one I hate VR porn I think it's like
terrifying it's Terr have you ever
watched it it seems terrifying Nazi like
it makes me a little sick the only way I
think someone can truly like VR porn is
if they like like gigantic ass porn
because like I'm just like everything's
so big like I'm like
it just feels huge to me so that's why I
feel like it's scary and also like the
first time I saw my C in VR I was like
oh I don't want to like see anything
that close like like it's like when fans
tweet they're like watching you on my 62
inch I'm like ew get the fuck off there
go back to yourself
why are you making it like gigantic
scares me how embarrassing yeah it feels
like it hasn't really I don't know that
Pat isn't the the Apple goggles are out
augmented reality coming out in probably
uh Christmas I don't know just to like
watch movies on and stuff
yeah you can do anything including have
your wife divorce you and I just feel
like it's a way to just check out
entirely yeah if I walked in and saw my
dude just like I'd be like do like yeah
this can't be good yeah are you getting
it you're getting it for sure
you're right people really do want to
ask you the same questions don't they
yeah
what is your I'm gonna remix this into
into a good question what is your ideal
date
my ideal day I don't even know if I can
answer this so I'm excited
so my ideal date would be being woken up
with eggs benedict
then going to Disneyland oh okay are you
a Disney adult I'm a Disney fucking
obsessive freak okay I Disney bound I'm
crazy so do you go with friends do you
go I have friends that go alone because
they both wild both have you done the
the back behind the scenes pass where
they like take you no I refuse I don't
want to see what it's like back there
it's like I keep the magic alive and
it's so funny because like if I ever go
with any other sex workers and they
start talking about sex I get like
really like
don't ruin this this is Disney you know
like I feel like it's like my only child
experience in child fun so I go a lot so
I think my perfect date would be Disney
and then we would probably leave before
the fireworks so we could come back and
Hike my dogs and then just maybe like
chill by my fire pit cute did you not
get to go to Disneyland as a kid
no never I didn't get anything nothing
nothing I grew up in like working on
farms and shit the Amish farms right
Amish farms uh I don't trust people that
didn't do some kind of farm work growing
up yeah you don't no I was telling I was
trying to tell my friend
um when my back was better I want to
have like a bail off I don't know if you
know what it is I who can carry the most
amount of Bales I have hay bales right
outside right now we can do this we're
heavy yeah but I'm good at it I was
trying I was telling my friend he's like
no oh I was like I'm telling you I was
12 years old it's a science you gotta
get them on your shoulders yeah they're
very cumbersome oblong and what people
don't realize about hay bales they're
spiky as shit yes yes unless you have
Alfalfa or whatever but was growing up
around animals do you feel like that
taught you a lot about
um
you know what's crazy is I didn't have
empathy for animals and I didn't even
want to be around animals until I met my
first dog
um I think it's because I was so tired
of them because I would take care of
them so much
yeah same thing with like children I'm
ironically so good with children but for
like the longest time I hated even being
in a room with kids because I would be
forced to stay home from school to watch
all these other kids these random kids
in Foster cares all the time sure to
where I was just like it was insane
kids like took me a second also because
they're so like needy and it like it's
just like I want this and you're like
yeah everyone wants that I forget to eat
candy all the time like you can't do it
you know and sort of like I think for me
it also helped me once I was able to
unlock the secret of just treat them
kind of like adults like they kind of
want to be treated like adults anyway
yeah because I was like I'm not gonna
baby a baby there's no point you know
but when you like treat a toddler like
you know play to the top of their
intelligence it starts to be a little
bit more fun yes and you're like you're
just a baby I'm like do you want to
drive the car they're like I love her
you know like you know what I think I
think the cool part and I think the
reason why I've changed is I recently
got a puppy and I know it's not a child
but for me it is
um and watching her discover the world
is so awesome like just watching her
like do things or be afraid of things
love things and grow into her own person
that's why I can see the joy of like
kids and having a kid or being around
kids because like all the way up to 18
they're still learning how to like be in
society and stuff like that so I think
the magic of children and teens and
stuff is watching them just discover
Life
yeah you get to relive it through them
you're like wow this is amazing you're
this is great for you I'm happy and then
you're watching like oh that's like
where it went wrong like I can see how
like everyone is born good and and
open-hearted and then the world just
breaks them down over time like no one's
born an asshole or maybe I don't know
um I mean look I'm not the person to ask
but you know animals have really helped
me dogs especially because they're like
if I just like saw myself the way my dog
sees me yeah that's like half the battle
something wise yeah I wish I could do
that you're so right I'm like I love my
dog so much I trust my dog's judgment
more than anyone my dog like when I
bring dudes home that were no good she'd
be like you know yeah like then why
don't I trust her judgment me yeah you
know she thinks I'm cool I must be not
be that much of a piece of trash that's
so true that's so true in relationships
I feel like you probably have you know
such a wisdom around this any like red
flags like I always ask people like red
flags bottom lines well I think so many
red flags nowadays it's just like
um first of all age like date within
your age your age bracket yeah I don't
care if older guys or whatever say girls
or girls say oh guys mature it's just
not appropriate because older people
have more um understandability to
victimize you and mold you into how they
want you to be
um I also say uh like any dude that's
gonna offer you like hey let's party
because that's kind of like like if
somebody's like giving you like party
drugs and stuff like that then that's
like that's also warps your your reality
on how you think about them yeah um so
those are red flags because that happens
to me all the time in LA
um
and then let's party it's also like it's
kind of saying I don't think my
personality is that great yeah I don't
think you'd like me otherwise like I
need this in order to form this Bond yes
like I've had so many guys even recently
that I'm like trying to go hang out with
one guy was like oh let's go to
Universal and he's like why do you
always ditch me and because after he
asked me to go to Universal an hour
before we were supposed to go he's like
we're gonna take some fucking mushrooms
and I'm just like no bro like no I don't
want to take mushrooms and be a
universal right now you know like maybe
when I was 23 but you'll never never get
out of the parking lot no Jurassic
parking on mushrooms are you insane no
no so I would say that's red flag
um and then you know there's this new
kind of like if it's plant medicine it's
not drugs yeah it's like we're doing
Ayahuasca we're doing mushrooms we're
doing weed like it yes it comes from the
Earth but you're still altering and
you're still sort of like not in reality
yeah and it can be overused yeah and
what's your intent like you shouldn't
listen when you're young you're gonna
try everything right but like you have
an attention when you're young oh to try
it for the first time to like get off
that right as you get older you start to
lose an intention to do it you're just
doing it to party yeah and I think if
you're gonna do anything that's
mind-altering you should have a goal for
the end of it and not just we're gonna
yeah we're gonna go to Madewell yeah at
Universal yeah like what the fuck like
have you done mushrooms have you had
good experiences with it um yeah I've
had really good really really good
experiences with it I had like a full
year of my life where I'd just go to
Disney On Acid
and those are like the best days of my
life dude in that case I'm a Disney
adult I get it now yo going to the
Haunted Mansion when it is the Christmas
theme on acid is fucking wild you're
just like this is the best thing ever
why is everyone here so little yes are
these children or midgets and it's crazy
because no one cares because like Disney
has so many type of people like you can
just be fucked up then they don't even
notice you know
like I was like stuck in in one of the
chairs like laughing one time and I was
like ah and I couldn't get out and the
lady just walks by and she's like oh
clip you know it's just sort of like you
guys all the adults here are wearing
Mouse ears yeah you think they're sober
yeah exactly so it's a good time but
then but like has that helped at all
with like the trauma stuff and like you
know with like doing mushrooms
um so I actually uh one time during the
pandemic uh did mushrooms and acid
together and it was so strong it
actually it was the Catalyst for
everything that I'm going through now
yeah I saw I saw it was really weird so
um once I was high I saw different
doorways on my wall and then I felt like
I was inside my mind and each doorway
was a different perspective of me and my
mom and that really sent me into a loop
I actually went and I was stuck in a
mental hospital for like seven days
um did you call for help or did someone
no my friend the next day I I took I
only took two sleeping pills but I was
like come over to my house because I'm
around my fire picks the next day I was
like on hinge
um and she was like I'm on hinge or
unhinged unhinged okay yeah and that's
the worst part of this story if you went
on hinge we need to get you no to the
hospital no
um and she was just really like worried
about me so she she just dropped me off
she was like I think this is what you
need to do which
um in a way
it was good that all those things
happened but being stuck in a a sane
Asylum uh the first week of the pandemic
was very scary because it was also one
that like local people's like the the
bad area you know yeah yeah so like they
were like a guy was like I'm here
because I wanted to murder someone so I
said if I was crazy I wouldn't get in
trouble you know and I'm like what the
fuck and the most bizarre thing about
the whole situation is I shared a room
with this girl who wouldn't stop
masturbating she had like a masturbation
problem and she was literally she had it
before she knew she was sharing a room
with you yeah she had no idea who he was
I walked in and she was like sorry I'm a
chronic masturbator I masturbate all the
time you know and I was just like what
the fuck are the odds of this and like
everything I have a number where you
could make a lot of money yeah and I'm
just like I can't touch this light
switch I can't fucking touch these
curves by the way I love that that's
only insane if you don't do it on only
fans yeah it's only insane that you're
doing it for free here
I would wake up to like
stop it I'm like no
I'm like I'm going more insane here you
know so it was really really ironic did
it do you feel like it was good that you
just were able to remove yourself for a
second or was do you feel like it was
just like comparatively I'm really
saying and I can go home uh why Laden I
actually most of the time laid in the
bed and I kept thinking I was my mother
like oh shit because she was in Mental
Hospitals on and off so it actually I
think broke me more but if I didn't get
out and have that experience to realize
like those are my fears and if I didn't
have the moment of feeling so broken I
wouldn't have sought help so that's the
first time in my life I was ever like
wow we need help and we need to figure
out what's going on in here and I refer
to myself as we because there's two
people yeah you know so it was a good
thing in a weird way yeah I mean I think
that that those hallucinogens like it
seems like everyone loves doing them and
they can go you know and for me it's
like we did mushrooms on a live podcast
and I was like oh this kind of just you
know it was such a low dosage it made me
almost it almost felt like
adderalli or something like I just like
talk really fast and think really
quickly because I wasn't like bogged
down by shame and embarrassment and
don't say that you're being an idiot you
know and uh and then when my mom died I
did some micro dosing mushrooms and I
was not thriving I was like Angry like
yeah anger came up you know and I think
I guess for a lot of people that don't
have as much trauma maybe it's just more
fun and exploratory and like we're alone
with plants I'm like I wasn't there yeah
you know I had so much anger I had so
much rage I had so much trauma I was
like oh like I don't I don't think this
is you know for me because I know so
many people in La that are just micro
dosing mushrooms kind of all day every
day yeah and I'm just like whenever like
hallucinogens come into the picture now
I'm like I don't want to get stuck there
right like I don't want to get stuck in
whatever that was you know that feeling
or that and it tricked me a little bit I
guess because yeah I was like I couldn't
cry like after my mom died I couldn't
cry and I felt guilty that I didn't feel
worse and she had been in a bed for 12
years and are obviously relationship
very you know fraught and um and I just
was like anger was coming up and then
you know anger is just sadness but I was
like I need to get I just need to cry
ultimately I need to grieve this thing
and it was just like my ego or my psyche
just trying to fight grieving and it was
like I was like I've never had anger
before and I was like I thought
mushrooms were supposed to make you like
happy Indigo dye your own fedoras they
want you to figure mushrooms are from
the earth it wants you to figure out
your shit you know yeah and I was like
oh anger's coming up I'm not this person
so I just need to like cry and like
maybe down the line it's a tool but I
think in general like I'm trying to you
know I haven't for you know since then
done any substances like at all really
but like I even went off I was taking
Lunesta to sleep like I was kind of just
like you know because you convince
yourself well if I just sleep more I'll
be fine you know but after my mom died I
realized you know there was so much
stuff that you know like pain you had to
just like feel it and like all these
ways of trying to get out of it whether
it's like work sex chronic masturbating
anything like I was just like I just
have to like feel this because it's just
like crystallizing inside me and grief
is so shitty grief is my first
experience with grief this was my dog so
it's just been so crazy it's like the
craziest experience because some days
I'll just like some days I'm just like
today I'm not doing anything I'm just
gonna lay in bed and cry and then some
days I'll wake up and I still it's been
eight months I'll wake up and I'll call
his name and then I'll forget and that
really breaks my heart so well
surrendering is like often the first
just being able to be in bed and cry and
be sad about it because like I'll I just
go into like I'm gonna just schedule
like I'm gonna do a 50 City Tour and I'm
gonna like get your mind off do this
this but it's just like crying it's like
that's the only way to get through and
then to be able to go like you know and
again like you know some of the trauma
therapy really helped me but just like
sobbing crying like oh like yeah kind of
crying belting felting yes and because
also well see I'm now I'm I'm gonna
release some emotion of animals dogs
like there's no way to get out of it
whereas like grieving you know my dad
and my mom you can take a day off by
going well he was kind of an asshole
yeah and you can sort of go into anger
as a way to not be in the sadness for a
day or you can just you know but like
dogs you can never say well he was an
app you can never do that yeah it was
just this unconditional love he was the
best and it sucks the most because
we never covered the body just the mess
so that really sucks because my heart
like knows he's dead but a lot of my
heart still is like what if so like
sometimes I drive by those mountains and
I just like I'm like me just still out
there
um because he was just so awesome
and sometimes I go there and I just lay
where I found all this Blood because I
just want to be close to him
it's like it's almost like it I don't
know why it hurts that I just couldn't
get anything you know and that's like
another reason why I feel like I haven't
gotten over it because I'm like I just
have nothing
to hold on to like I I'm so lucky I
found his old harness that had hair in
it because I'm like that's all I have
left
and it's it's so crazy it's just I've
never followed it before you miss him
have you gotten a tattoo I'm getting I'm
actually gonna help I'm gonna get his
face right here it really helps who's
gonna do it I don't know yet because I
don't I've never gotten a tattoo I don't
know anybody that doctor would I think
would be perfect it's like it's um yeah
I've started the process of
[Laughter]
nothing
and I think that you know people like us
like when you never had unconditional
love like when you get that you know
it's like God damn it you God damn it
um I know and then uh and uh it's like
you've never had that feeling before you
know at least I've never had that
feeling before my dogs are just like
my life you know and um but having like
a sort of some sort of permanent imprint
of them like really helps like remind us
that like even when they're gone you
know the what the way that they changed
our hearts is permanent and always stays
with us you know and um but dude God
damn it and it's also like dogs they
also do this other magical thing where
you know when we grieve them like other
grief comes I mean it's like old grief
comes up old stuff comes up and you know
even when I hear about someone else's
it's just like so much sadness comes up
because they just like
they're nice they're just the best
creatures like my other dog pork he sat
with me every single day he even got fat
while I was injured if I went to the
bathroom he'd go to the bathroom I never
asked him to do these things but he
learned how to like roll my water bottle
over to me and my pill bottle over to me
so he was so nice and another crazy
thing not to make you cry but
um I feel bad for him because he didn't
get to grieve right to see the body
um but when I was looking for him the
reason why I found the spot where there
was all the blood was because I had pork
and I was saying sniff sniff sniff sniff
and he was the one who took me to that
spot so I'm like oh God it's like even
traumatic for him because there's
nothing to say goodbye like yeah I'm
like what do you like and I'm also crazy
because I wanted to Taxidermy and my
dogs
look I wanted to Taxidermy them and like
put them in a frame so I'm just like
when I I'm not at that bridge yet who
knows I've looked into cloning like I've
that's I love that though it's no I mean
it's really no good like what it does
like it's really inhumane it's obviously
costs a fortune and you get them and
they're like wonky yeah and a lot of
people that I was deep in the chat rooms
of the dog cloning and they're like this
is even worse it's just like a Bizarro
version like zombie version of the dog I
had the same Souls not there it's not
the same dog like they just have health
issues I think my new dog has part of my
old dog soul
I I picked her and it's so weird because
he had a broken tail so it's crooked
um and he eats the dirt in one spot in
my yard and he used to lay in one spot
on one spot of the couch and it's so
weird because when she showed up she had
a broken fucking tail She lays in that
one spot and she eats the same dirt so
I'm like you are a little bit of him
like you might not fully be him but some
part of him went to you and his name was
God and I named her Naya which means in
God's hands so I was like wow you're
meant to be a part of him so that's it's
been really cool to have her
yeah yeah it's crazy
well I'm a squirter now from my face
um thank you so much for doing this
thank you thank you for having me being
such an Angel
um so uh we are still on only fans just
not
just being emotionally vulnerable yes
right yes there's something so much
kinkier about like you with your clothes
on I feel like I was thinking I'm gonna
just start doing like house tours like
just normal and just be like what's up
this is me folding laundry you know
that's I mean a lot of the our friend
Alex who um uh is head of marketing and
only fans who had that cam girl company
before he's like a lot of the biggest
ones were just like doing chore like
someone just kind of wants a companion
totally can't jerk off all day I mean
that woman can that you shared a room
with she really fucking can it's really
wild you know but it's also just
sometimes like just you know uh who
there was some I'm trying to think yeah
there was someone else on only fans that
kind of just did like really basic stuff
and you know I think some people I think
go for a lot of different I mean I'm
putting comedy on there you know and
people are going instead of dirty photos
and dirty videos I'm doing like dirty
jokes like jokes I can't tell other
places or I'll get canceled or like you
know the beginning version of a joke
where you're like trying to figure it
out and like I haven't cracked it yet
but if I try it out on stage and
someone's filming with their camera
phone before it's ready you know what's
going to happen you know so it's like I
think that it's already becoming so
popular for other reasons and I see like
you know so many people doing well on
their
I think it's just like evolving and
changing a lot totally and then oft TV
yeah I've done a few videos
um no but I think oh we already have it
it's you doing you work in Walmart
Adriana does it yeah like I'm so in
um you're an angel thank you for coming
on thank you for having me all right
don't ride elephants goodbye
[Music]
I've been
Jesu Joe's input is General
psychological information based on
research and clinical experience it is
intended to be General and informational
in nature it does not represent or
indicate established clinical or
professional relationship with those
inquiring for guidance also just because
you might have heard something on the
show that sounds similar to what you've
been experiencing beware excuse me of
self-diagnosis and that Coca-Cola which
got me good diagnosis is not required to
find relief and you'll want to find a
qualified professional to assess and
explore diagnoses if that's important to
you if you or your partner are in crisis
and uncertain of whether you can
maintain safety reach out for support
crisis hotlines local authorities have a
safety plan that can be done with a
therapist too
[Applause]